Tom Brady is allowed to play and own the
same NFL team he says he's done playing
football but he also refuses to rule out
playing again and now that he's almost
an owner of the Las Vegas Raiders this
could happen but there are of course
rules 75 of the league owners will need
to approve it and personally if I'm an
owner I'm not passing this because why
the hell would I want my team facing
another team with Tom Brady on it but
this would make a lot of sense for the
Raiders who just signed Jimmy Garoppolo
with a banged up foot it would also be a
great way to work around salary cap and
it wouldn't be the first time that Tom
Brady took less money than he deserved